in this series are neoplatonism that me
and my dear colleagues have put together
so far we have dealt with the topic from
various angles and perspectives both
neoplatonism itself but also how it has
influenced various different religious
and philosophical traditions across
history
but with all that there is still a huge
hole in the discussion that has yet to
be filled a hole that looks suspiciously
like the largest religion in the world
Christianity
indeed while it hasn't been properly
acknowledged earlier in history there is
no doubt to Scholars today that
neoplatonism had a massive influence on
the early history and Theology of
Christianity helping to shape some of
the core features and Creeds of that
religion so let's Trace some of the
places where we can find this
relationship between neoplatonism and
Christianity
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
the first lines of the Gospel of John
says quote in the beginning was the word
and the Word was with God and the Word
was God
the word word is a translation of the
Greek term logos which is a complicated
philosophical word this shows us that
even in the gospels themselves
Christianity was in dialogue with Greek
or Hellenic thought
while their religion essentially grew
out of Judaism it's also clear that its
Origins are intertwined with all the
intellectual and religious currents that
existed in the Mediterranean region in
the first centuries A.D as most of us
know Christianity as we know it didn't
happen overnight after the death of
Jesus there followed many centuries of
debates discussions divisions and
developments before we reached anything
like an Orthodoxy or many of the
mainstream beliefs that we associate
with the religion today and in all of
those developments Christian thinkers
remained in dialogue with other currents
and schools of thought
one of these was of course the major
School of neoplatonism
while platonism as a whole is of course
traced back to Plato who lived several
centuries BC neoplatonism or late
platonism is a further development of
that philosophical tradition the origins
of which is usually traced through the
3rd Century philosopher platinus and his
successors like porphery iamblicus and
proclus
if you want a thorough introduction to
platinus and neoplatonism as a whole you
should check out my previous video
dealing with that topic in particular as
well as the excellent companion videos
by my fellow collaborators but as a very
short summary neoplatonism sometimes
called blade platonism is a late antique
development within platonism primarily
associated with again figures like
platinus it conceives of existence as
consisting of different levels or
realities hypotheses in Greek beginning
with the highest one tohen which cannot
be understood or described in any way
being hidden in a radical epiphatic
Darkness this one then emanates or you
could say flows over into something
called the news which is often
translated with words like intellect or
mind which is the archetype of all
things in the world and is also of
course the place of the platonic forms
news then also emanates into these
so-called Soul or World Soul sometimes
which in turn creates the world of
nature or our physical Universe of time
and space
the neoplatonists then conceive of a
return back from the physical up the
ladder of reality and back to the Noose
and even to the one
everything flows from the one and
returns to the one and the goal of the
human being is to turn away from
physicality and material things
traveling Inward and contemplating his
true noetic reality thus returning to
his home in The Noose and there
experiencing a mystical Unity with that
noose and even ultimately with the one
itself
again this is a criminally short and
simplified rundown and there is a lot
more to neoplatonism and the thought of
people like platinus so I really suggest
you go watch my earlier dedicated
episode first before continuing on well
with this episode
neoplatonism quickly became an
incredibly widespread and influential
School of philosophy and came to
prominence around the same time that
some of the most influential Christian
Church fathers and theologians lived and
worked and we find in these thinkers
clear indications of their engagement
with and influence by the late platonist
this is perhaps most visible in figures
like origin the cappadocian fathers such
as Gregory of Nissa Augustine and
perhaps of course above all the pseudo
dionysius
so what are these indications exactly
and how have they impacted Christianity
as a whole
to start off we can discuss the
fascinating figure origin of Alexandria
a person has had a quite complicated
relationship with Christian Orthodoxy
he was an incredibly popular and
influential figure in his day even being
considered the first truly Christian
Theologian but in later periods with the
formation of Orthodoxy he and his ideas
were often criticized and even condemned
by the church
you might find it kind of weird to talk
about origin in relation to neoplatonism
after all he died before the founder of
neapolitanism itself the timeus so can
there really be any connection here at
all
well one of the things that are so
interesting about origin is that he
might have had a personal relationship
with patanus himself indeed in the life
of platinus written by his student
porphry we are told that platina studied
in Alexandria under a teacher called
ammonius sakas
he also tells us that platinus's fellow
students included a guy called
origin
while this is a disputed question many
signs indicate that this origin and the
Christian Theologian might be one and
the same person
our origin was from Alexandria just like
the Titus he lived at around the same
time and also seems to have studied
under a teacher called ammonius
so it is quite possible that platinus
and origin studied together and shared
the same platonist teacher which might
give us Clues as to why we find ideas in
origin that certainly appear at least
somewhat neoplatonists or at least
certainly platonist in nature origin is
famous for a number of ideas and
teachings he wrote and preached several
commentaries on Biblical scriptures
where he is famous for his strongly
allegorical readings
readings where Biblical verses are often
given platonistic interpretation in
these allegorical readings he drew
significantly on predecessors such as
the fellow alexandrian and first century
Jewish philosopher Philo another very
significant platonizing figure
scripture always comes first to origin
but there is no denying the fact that he
interpreted it according to
philosophical principles and
specifically platonism
the story of Adam and Eve seems that
he's partly to be a symbolic story
depicting how immaterial souls in the
noetic world descend into the material
Realm
quartz and the expulsion of the man and
woman from Paradise and they're being
clothed with tunics of skins which God
because of the transgression of men made
for those who had sinned contain a
certain secret and mystical Doctrine for
transcending that of Plato of the souls
losing its wings and being born downward
to Earth until we can lay hold of some
stable resting place
and this brings us to one of those
really famous teachings of origin and
one of those that he would be greatly
criticized for later the fact that he
believed in the pre-existence of Souls
in true platonist fashion origin holds
that Souls exist before they are born
into this world there is in other words
a kind of hierarchy the immaterial world
of pure Souls being above the physical
world and our present existence here
being a kind of descent downward partly
represented by the fall of Adam and Eve
indeed when we look deeper into Origins
Theology and cosmology we find some
clear parallels with platonism and
sometimes things are even close to
neoplatonism first of all he conceives
of God Jose in an apophatic way
in other words our human Minds cannot
understand or grasp God as he is beyond
our conception and things like time and
space god is a perfect immaterial and
incorporeal unity although he does of
course include the Son and the Holy
Spirit in the system too there are a few
things that are often said to
characterize neoplatonism as it emerged
around the same time as zevi pointed out
in his earlier video on neoplatonism in
Kabbalah there are often three
particular themes that are used to trace
neoplatonism and its influence
number one is epiphaticism or apathetic
theology number two is the idea of
emanation that reality somehow emanates
from this one down to this material
world and then returns back to it and
lastly the idea of Union mystica that
one can become one or United with the
highest principle in some way this is a
core feature in neoplatonism that we are
to return from the physical back to the
one and become United to the one so in
our discussion about neoplatanism and
Christianity we're going to keep an eye
out for these details of these features
in particular at least ideas that are
similar or related to these ideas we
don't find these exact themes in origin
to be clear with the possible exception
of his relatively mild epiphaticism and
this maybe isn't surprising given the
fact that it was an older contemporary
of Tinus but there are a few significant
similarities between origin and and
certainly platonism which no one would
doubt but also with neoplatonism origen
goes on to talk about the Noose and
other key platonic concept and in some
spots he seemed to identify God the
Father with the news itself in other
spots though he seems to see God the
father as being higher than the news
which is significant and perhaps
predicted the conceptions of the one in
platinus and his successors origin is
also very famous and controversial for
supposedly holding the idea of Epic
catastes the conception that everything
created will at some point return to its
origins in Perfection essentially the
idea that everyone or everything will
eventually be saved
hell in this case however it is
interpreted is thus not Eternal but
everyone there will eventually reach
salvation
origen was accused of holding this idea
even to the point of saying that the
Devil Himself will be saved and this was
another point that he was strongly
condemned for
although Scholars will point out that
this is somewhat of a misrepresentation
Origins views are actually a lot more
nuanced than that for sure though he
seems to hold an idea close to this
which also partly and probably stems
back to his platonism
if God is infinitely good which origin
presumes then can he really allow people
to suffer forever it's the age-old
question
to origin God's goodness seems to
preclude that everything will eventually
return to its original Perfection here I
can't help but see that other
characteristic neoplatonic doctrine that
everything flows from the one and
eventually returns back to the one
here in origin everything must similarly
return back to the first principle which
in this case is of course God
so to origin a god that is infinitely
good cannot possibly allow people to
suffer forever so to origin everyone
must eventually be saved in the same way
in a sort of platonic language that
everything that comes from the one or
God in this case must return to to God
must return to the one so everything
must go eventually go back to that
original perfection in unity with the
one I will admit that these neoplatonic
Connections in origin are based on some
speculation and stretching things a bit
but we can be sure that he was an
important factor in the entrance of
platonism in general into Christian
thought which would later take on the
language of neoplatonism in particular
just listen to this section of origin
talking about prayer and how the
practice of prayer can lead to a
contemplation and maybe even Union with
God and tell me it doesn't sound like a
passage straight from platinus quote
for the eyes of the Mind are lifted up
from their preoccupation with Earthly
things and from there being filled with
the impression of material things
and they are so exalted that they peer
beyond the created order and arrive at
the sheer contemplation of God and at
conversing with him reverently and
suitably as he listens
how would things so great fail to profit
those eyes that gaze at the glory of the
Lord with unveiled face
and that are being changed into his
likeness from glory to glory
for them they partake of some Divine and
intelligible radiance
I mean come on
as we said many of these ideas of origin
would eventually be highly criticized
and condemned and he remains a somewhat
contested figure
but there's no doubt whatsoever that he
still greatly influenced later key
Christian Church fathers and thinkers
even though they often sort of cleaned
up some of the more controversial
aspects of his thoughts and he thus had
a major impact on Christian theology
even if sometimes indirectly
even such paradigms of Orthodoxy such as
athanasius a key person in the formation
of the doctrine of the Trinity was
massively influenced by origin another
group of Scholars that clearly took
inspiration from the ideas of origin and
perhaps more directly from neoplatonism
where the so-called cappadocian fathers
which included basil the great Gregory
of Nissa and Gregory of naziensis
it's also worth mentioning the sister of
the first two macrina as a significant
figure in this context these
cappadocians are considered some of the
most foundational scholars in Christian
history and in terms of Christian
doctrines especially in the Eastern
church or what is often called Orthodox
Christianity the most quote-unquote
philosophical of the bunch was probably
Gregory of Nissa and in his as well as
the others writings we continue to see
traces of some of those main neoplatonic
themes it's interesting to point out
that among Scholars it's often
considered that the category of
Christian mysticism kind of starts with
the cappadocians
while we see traces of it in writings by
origin or maybe even Clement of
Alexandria it's really with writers like
Gregory of Nissa that mysticism starts
to become a thing in Christianity
properly
and this is perhaps primarily through
their discussion of ineffability and
apothesis we mentioned in the earlier
episode that the language of what we
call mysticism owes a lot to figures
like platinus in particular and their
influence and that is perhaps visible
here
Gregory of Nissa talks about how God is
beyond all human understanding or the
ability of our minds to grasp we can
never know the essence of God because
God is per definition unknowable
these discussions were partly in
response to arguments made by the Aryans
or really the so-called neo-aryans who
argue that we can know the essence of
God directly through his names
since God the father is unbegotten this
very name says something directly about
the nature of the father that we can
thus know
it also leads to the conclusion that the
father is superior to the sun since the
sun is begotten whereas the father is
unbegotten
Gregory of Nissa and the cappadocians
are trying to defend the Nicene or
Orthodox conception of the Trinity by
rejecting any such claims God is totally
unknowable and Beyond us
and Gregory really takes this
epiphaticism to new heights in his
writings indeed earlier figures like
origen also spoke of God apathetically
but not to as extreme of a degree as
Gregory of Nissa
earlier God may have been infinite and
boundless thus unknowable through the
sheer magnitude of God so to say God is
infinite in such a way that no human
mind can know him but it is conceivable
that there could be a human that had a
perfect unbounded mind that would be
able to know God
but Gregory of Nissa takes it further
God is completely beyond all categories
of knowing altogether
he is so utterly Transcendent that our
words or Minds simply aren't even in the
same ballpark
he is not infinite in the sense of
extending indefinitely but in the sense
that he is beyond all time and space
beyond all conceptions of limit
in other words Gregory seems to be a bit
closer to someone like platinus in his
conception of the one
but he also makes some interesting
Innovations
because it is with the cappadocians that
we first see the descriptions of God as
a Darkness
God is the unknowable darkness beyond
all things
this way of talking about the absolute
principle which would perhaps get its
most full expression in these
pseudo-dionysius has become so famous
and widely used to talk about the
platonic one that I even use this kind
of language in my video on your
platonism even though platinus himself
never really describes the one in this
way
earlier the one was talked about in
terms of of light more so right but it
is with Gregory that we see this
language of Darkness God or in plutinian
language the one is an utter darkness of
Unknowing and this is the first time we
see this language and this will become
incredibly influential very popular
especially in the Eastern Orthodox
Church this way of talking about God and
in mysticism
so to say is incredibly widespread and
popular and it kind of starts with the
cappadocians and with Gregory in
particular the cappadocians were greatly
influenced by origin even though they
cleaned up many of the more
controversial aspects associated with
him
whether they were directly influenced by
neoplatonism perhaps having read
platinus or porphyry is more uncertain
a lot of the ideas definitely seem to
remind us of someone like platinus but
this could very well have been
indirectly through for example the
platonizing Tendencies of origin there
is no clear direct evidence that they
read the original Pagan neoplatonist
even though many want to argue for this
position but for example they seem to
pick up on the idea of apocatastises
especially Gregory of Nissa
just like origen he seems to argue that
everything comes from God perhaps even
emanates from God but that it must
eventually also return back to God
this means that everyone or everything
will be saved right
punishment is not Eternal for anyone
rather being a kind of purification
but in true neoplatonic fashion he
argues for the idea of the outflow and
inflow going out and returning back that
is such a key feature of neoplatonism
so already we have found two of those
main characteristics that we mentioned
earlier the epiphaticism and the
emanation although slightly modified of
course
but we can even find that third feature
the idea of union mystica or mystical
Union indeed a very central theme for
the cappadocians and for much of later
theology especially in the Eastern
Orthodox Church is the concept of
theosis or literally becoming God
Gregory of naziensis together with
figures like athanasius like to say
quote God became human so that we might
become God
theosis is a complex topic and one that
can often be misunderstood but in short
terms it's basically the idea that the
ultimate goal is one of uniting with God
which has been a prominent feature of
Orthodoxy throughout history
the Russian Orthodox Theologian
vladimiryloski wrote quote the
theological doctrines which have been
elaborated in the course of these
struggles can be treated in the most
direct relation to the vital end that of
Union with God to the attainment of
which they are subservient
this uniting with God has been
interpreted in many different ways by
different people and theologians but
generally it does not mean that the
person becomes directly United or become
one with God in his Essence but rather
that he somehow participates in the
Divine Life as some would put it indeed
this very point was the source for the
so-called hesicast controversy in the
Eastern Orthodox Church that erupted in
the Middle Ages where great thinkers
like Gregory palamas would formulate a
very influential distinction between
God's Essence and his Energies
now this is a complicated Topic in
itself and I've dedicated a full
previous episode to that if you want to
check it out nonetheless the theme of
fiosis or uniting with God has become a
key feature of Orthodox Christianity and
we can find this idea already in the
cappadocians
quote in the unfathomable Darkness one
communes with God through faith
Gregory of Nissa talks about faith as
the faculty of Union as opposed to
platinus's emphasis on the higher news
or intellect and Gregory has a
fascinating perspective on Union one
that teaches that this experience is one
that never ends since God is infinite
the person in faith never stops
traveling in other words the journey
never ends quote
This truly is the vision of God never to
be satisfied in the desire to see him
No Limit would interrupt growth in the
ascent to God since no limit to the good
can be found nor is the increasing of
desire for the good brought to an end
because it is satisfied
but all these themes of apathetic
Darkness emanation and mystical Union
find their most dramatic expression in
Antiquity with the absolutely
fascinating figure of pseudo-dionysius
here my job gets kind of easy because
finding neoplatonic themes in pseudo
dionysius isn't exactly much of a
challenge he is one of the most
significant and interesting characters
in the history of mysticism apophaticism
and esotericism and what makes this
extra juicy is that we don't even know
who he was
he took on the name or claimed to be
dionysius the areopagites an obscure
figure in the Bible that became a
Christian when Paul visited Athens
he is literally mentioned once in
passing in the New Testament and the
author that we are talking about claimed
to be this figure and to have witness
significant events in the Bible such as
seeing the thunderstorm that happened as
a result of Jesus's crucifixion
we know with pretty strong confidence
that he isn't who he says he is though
and that is widely accepted that the
so-called pseudo-dionysius wrote his
Works hundreds of years after the
biblical stories
in particular Scholars argued that he
must have been active around the year
500 A.D why are we so sure about this
well because in his writings he seems to
borrow a lot directly from the
neoplateness writer proclus who died in
485 and the first instances were
pseudo-dionysius writings are mentioned
by others are a few decades into the 6th
century
so he must have written his Works
somewhere in between those States after
proclus because he seems to be so
heavily influenced by the writings of
proclus but before of course when the
first
outside authors mention his writings and
this puts him somewhere around the year
500 A.D so we don't know who he was and
we don't know really when he lived
although we do have a pretty good idea
of the general period what we do know is
that he wrote some works that are
incredible and that would be massively
influential not only did he Pioneer
apathetic Theology and take it to a
whole new level played a massive role in
how we use the word Mystic and mysticism
today but he also basically invented the
word hierarchy through his use of the
turbine works like the celestial
hierarchy and the ecclesiastical
hierarchy
ecclesiasticus
where he Maps out the well hierarchy of
the angel Realms and worldly church but
he is perhaps most famous at least in
connection to our discussion today for
two other works the Divine names Theon
honomatom and the mystical theology
Mystic case theologies
these are two true masterpieces of
epiphaticism and mysticism that would
have a lasting impact until today
indeed the word mysticism which we often
contest and question is broader use
comes of course out of a Christian
framework in particular and in a way it
is here with the mystical Theology of
pseudo dionysius but the term starts
being used in a way that we would
recognize today so the whole concept of
mysticism as we know it in some ways can
be traced to pseudonymysius when we read
the mystical theology which is a rather
short work some very short work actually
we find an author that is primarily
concerned with the unknowable nature of
God with a strongly apathetic theology
where God cannot be grasped by the mind
but rather only experienced through
going into the darkness beyond all
things where God dwells
and in fact one of the things that
struck us the most about his writings is
just how neoplatonic he is
indeed his neoplatonism is so strong and
prominent that many scholars are unsure
whether to characterize him as a
neoplitanizing Christian or a
christianizing neoplatonist in
particular he seems to follow and adapt
very closely in the form of neoplatonism
associated with the aforementioned
proclus author of works like the
elements of theology
in any case pseudo-dionysius whoever he
was is clearly working from a
neoplatonist philosophical framework and
is using that framework in service of a
Christian theology which he uses to
interpret scripture in all of this it is
that apophenicism and divine darkness
that is at the core of his teachings
as Vladimir lovski writes when talking
about pseudodynesius quote now God is
beyond all that exists in order to
approach him it is necessary to deny all
that is inferior to him that is to say
all that which is
if in seeing God one can know what one
sees then one has not seen God in
himself but something intelligible
something which is inferior to him
It Is by unknowing that one may know him
who is above every possible object of
knowledge
proceeding by negations one ascends from
the inferior degrees of being to the
highest by progressively setting aside
all that can be known in order to draw
near to the unknown in the darkness of
absolute ignorance
God is utterly beyond anything created
or anything that can be imagined
basically identical to the platinian one
to quote unquote No God one has to
abandon all forms of knowing
the only path to God is through
unknowing where we enter into the
darkness of Unknowing within ourselves
and there God is
Union with God is a process of removing
all things until only that Divine
Darkness remains
again as we said with Gregory of Nissa
this talk about God as Darkness was
incredibly revolutionary and would be
taken up by thinkers for the rest of
History it is a brilliant way of talking
about these near platonic Concepts that
has become very popular across the board
in the mystical theology dionysius uses
a fastening example from scripture to
talk about and justify this conception
of the Divine namely the story of
Moses's Ascent of Mount Sinai in the
book of Exodus
this event while it may have happened in
a literal sense too is read
allegorically or esoterically as a
description of an inward ascent
when Moses goes up the mountain he is
really going inward away from all people
or outside Concepts contemplating The
Depths within himself or rather going
through the gradual process of Unknowing
of casting off all conceptions or
knowledge as we usually Define it
eventually he reaches the peak and at
the book of Exodus very tellingly says
quote then the people stood at a
distance while Moses Drew near to the
thick Darkness where God was
dionysius thus finds the language of
Darkness here directly in the Bible and
it does finds perfect parallels with his
new platonic philosophical leanings he
talks about this peak of Moses's journey
and the mystical path in a very
platinian way quote
but then he Moses breaks free of them
away from what sees and is seen and he
plunges into the truly mysterious
darkness of Unknowing
here renouncing all that the Mind May
conceive wrapped entirely in the
intangible and the invisible he belongs
completely to him who is beyond
everything
here being neither oneself or someone
else one is supremely United to the
completely Unknown by an inactivity of
all knowledge and knows beyond the Mind
by knowing nothing
pseudo-dionysus is a really fascinating
figure
he was both incredibly criticized and
even called a heretic shortly after he
lived but he has also become one of the
most influential thinkers in the history
of Christianity especially in the
Eastern Orthodox Church where his ideas
are basically part of mainstream
theology he had a few rough centuries
but by the Middle Ages people like
Thomas Aquinas were commenting on his
works as a major Church Authority thus
cementing him as a key figure in the
history of of Christian thought we also
find clear influences from Dionysus in
one of the most famous medieval
Christian Catholic Mystics maester
Eckhart Eckhart similarly talks about
how God's ground and the ground of the
soul is identical and that this ground
is a kind of Darkness deep within the
reality of the soul and of all things
in general the thought of Meister
Eckhart is greatly neoplatonic in nature
not only does he adopt the radical
epiphaticism of pseudodionesius but also
talks about the creation of the world
through outflow and inflow usgank and
ingonk in Middle High German literally
going out and going in
God emanates or overflows into the
universe which eventually must always
return back to its origins in the Divine
ground
the goal of the human being is to detach
from all created things and break
through into the ground where God and
the Soul are one and the same ground
quote now no all of our Perfection and
our Holiness rests in this
that a person must penetrate and
transcend everything created and
temporal and all-being and go into the
ground that has no ground
or in the words of the scholar Bernard
mcginn quote eckhart's mystical way will
be an invitation to the soul to give up
the nothingness of its created self in
order to become the Divine nothing that
is also all things
this language of Eckhart is not only
very neoplatonic as you can clearly see
but also strongly pseudo-dynesian in its
emphasis on the Divine as a kind of
nothingness or Darkness
and we continue to see this influence in
thinkers connected to or similar to
Eckhart such as his students Henry suso
and Johannes Taylor or layer thinkers
like Nicholas of kuza
and speaking of Catholicism some of its
most foundational figures also had a
connection to neoplatanism while the
Catholic and Orthodox Churches generally
share the same church fathers and key
figures different ones often play
different roles in these two branches
the cappadocians and pseudo-dionysius
are more emphasized in the Orthodox
Church for example even though they are
of course very important for the Western
Branch too
but perhaps the most significant early
figure for Catholicism or the western
church is after all Augustine
whose works and thought would lay the
groundwork for much of the Latin church
for the rest of History
he was as many of you will know
originally an admirer of the religion of
manichaeism founded by the prophet Mani
in the 3rd Century later though he also
deeply studied neoplatonism and was
devoted to that philosophical school
before converting to Christianity
and even as a Christian while he would
of course strongly disagree with and
criticize much of quote-unquote pagan
philosophy we can also see that it
brings a lot of his neoplatonism with
him and applies it to his new
understanding of the Christian faith
indeed in his famous confessions he
basically states that it was studying
The Works of the neoplatonist that led
him to the truth of Christianity
thus affirming that figures like
platinus and porphyry had reached
certain truths about the Divine even
though they never accepted Christianity
and could be saved so to say Augustine's
neoplatonism is definitely there even
though it is often modified and can be
seen works like on the Trinity where he
talks about the Mind as a kind of well
as a trinity
we can see clear similarities here with
figures like patinas and other
platonists and their idea of Mind
firstly the idea that we are ultimately
immaterial Souls that survive the body
but also in the more particular ideas
about how the mind works in a
metaphysical sense
but while platinus would conceive of the
mind or intellect The Noose as twofold
it is a mind that is contemplating
itself thus being both that which
contemplates and that which is
contemplated
Augustine Builds on this model but
creates his own version based on his
Christian faith since humans are made in
the image of God as the Bible says this
means that the Trinity can be found or
reflected in the constitution of the
human being specifically in the mind
he presents various ways in which the
human mind or Soul can be said to be a
trinity landing on a Division into
memory understanding and will
now just like in the episode on
neoplatonism in Islam we should remember
that figures like Augustine and other
Scholars we have talked about don't see
themselves as taking neoplatonism and
applying it to Christianity or of trying
to fit Christianity into a neoplatonic
framework or the other way around rather
they saw philosophies like platonism as
rational ways of talking about or
thinking about what they already
believed through scripture of explaining
rationally things that they could
already find in scriptures
it was a useful language that could lead
to certainty on the intellectual plane
but it was always secondary to
revelation
nonetheless we can clearly see Titanic
or perhaps new platonic influence on
Augustine and his anthropology
epistemology and even theology
in general though the later Middle Ages
and the rise of scholasticism in the
Catholic West to generalize saw a move
away from platonism and more strongly
toward a kind of rationalizing
aristotelianism represented Above All by
figures like Thomas Aquinas this cannot
be said to the same degree in eastern
Orthodoxy which always kept these
features as core aspects of their
tradition but in the Catholic and later
Protestant churches there was less
emphasis on platonous thinking and thus
things like mysticism but of course
remember that we are greatly
generalizing now too we do see a can of
flatness Revival in Western Christianity
during the Renaissance with figures like
marcilio ficino and pico de la mirandola
which is definitely a topic that can be
explored in another fourth episode but
neoplatonism was for a long time ignored
as a major influence on Christianity
including in a scholarship and its role
has of course been significantly
decreased in the last few centuries
it's only relatively recently that
Scholars have once again realized just
how influential neoplatonism really was
not just on Christianity but on Western
thoughts and religion in general
returning to the earliest centuries it
isn't just true that significant Church
fathers and early theologians employed
platonist Concepts and thinking in
service of Christian theology a lot of
the very theological language that was
used in the great debates and councils
were heavily flavored by the
philosophical language at the time
all the debates about the Trinity or the
nature of Christ could not have been had
in the same way that it was without the
philosophical basis of schools like
neoplatonism to frame those discussions
in just consider the basic doctrine of
the Trinity as it became canonized in
its Orthodox form in the accounts of the
nicaea and of course in subsequent
developments after that including the
important works of the cappadocians
which we talked about
in conceptualizing how the Trinity Works
mainstream Christianity decided that God
is one in substance or Essence using the
Greek word usia
but he is three in hypotheses which is
usually translated as persons
but the term hypotheses the singular
witches hypothesis is the term used by
platinus to talk about the three
realities of his metaphysical system the
one The Noose and the soul
in other words Christian Theology and
Dogma was formed using Concepts and
words from schools like near platonism
today as we said it isn't talked about
as much as it maybe should be
there are Christians who take influence
from neoplatonism either directly or
indirectly the platonizing doctrines of
figures like these pseudodionesius and
Gregory of Nissa continue to be
foundational for the Eastern Orthodox
Church whose mysticism and apathetic
theology remind us a lot of this larger
tradition
in the western churches its presence is
harder to see but with the increased
popularity of figures like Meister
eckhart's among some people today we can
see neoplatonic ideas popping up here as
well this has inevitably been a very
brief and inadequate introduction to
this topic just a way of looking at the
some of the general ways that
neoplatonism and Christianity have
interacted throughout history especially
in the earliest developments of the
church
of course
many of these topics that we have
discussed including people like pseudo
dionysius all definitely deserve and
maybe will get dedicated episodes that
we can go through them more properly and
in depth but I hope this episode has at
least peaked your interest a little bit
and for sure the many ways that
neoplatonism has influenced and
interacted with Christianity shows us
once again just how influential and
important this school
if we can call it a school our
philosophy has really been throughout
history
in no way are we done talking about
neoplatonism on this channel of course
but now we have together covered the
three major abrahamic religions in their
relationship to near platonism I've done
one on Islam and now Christianity and
zevi of course did his uh episodes on on
neoplatanism and Judaism or Kabbalah in
particular so definitely go check out
his videos about neoplatonism and
Kabbalah as well as all the other videos
by my fellow collaborators Angela puka
from Angela Symposium John vervaki from
his channel and Justin Sledge from
esoterica and of course Dana trell from
the modern hermeticist they've all made
incredible videos on on this topic
really we've kind of created as
danatrell once said in the comment and
kind of made a whole free course about
neoplatonism together here on YouTube
which is just amazing so go check out
their amazing videos as always of course
I would like to thank all my patrons for
supporting this Channel and I would not
be able to do any of this without you so
return on the grateful and humbled that
you want to support me I would highly
appreciate of course if anyone else
wanted to become a patron and support
this channel I will leave links to that
in the description you can also support
this channel through a one-time donation
on PayPal you can also just simply like
comment and subscribe to the channel
uh I really appreciate all of you
watching engaging and and and yeah just
engaging with with these videos it's an
honor for me to share all this wonderful
uh knowledge to to share this passion
for Learning and studying things with
you guys in the audience so I I'm so
thankful to be able to do this
um thank you again
I'll see you next time
[Music]
thank you